the first priority of people who should
get this vaccine
are our frontline healthcare workers and
elderly americans those who are
over 65 years of age and who have been
proven throughout this entire
uh pandemic are many many times more
likely to die
if they get this virus than those who
are younger
and healthy unfortunately
the recommendations that are coming out
of the cdc do not reflect
what has been established by science
you tried to add a little honesty and
decency and everything
that you just described in your last few
weeks in congress so i want to go
through a few of the things that you
were you were really talking about and
trying to make happen
uh let's talk about the the covid
vaccine because you've been pretty
outspoken about how we've we've really
butchered some of what we're doing here
in terms of the rollout this this may
shock people but i really strongly have
been pushing
our cdc and their advisory committees as
well as our state leadership here in
hawaii
leaders across the country to make their
decisions based on medical science
about who should receive this vax who
what's the priority
given the limited amount of vaccine
available who needs to receive it first
if you look at medical science you would
find that based on
uh the all of the trials that have been
done it has been scientifically
established that this vaccine
is effective in preventing serious
health complications
from kovid and even death it has not
been scientifically established that
this vaccine is effective
in um stopping this virus from being
transmitted from one person
to another so if you look at both of
those
facts that have been scientifically
established you would draw the
conclusion that
the first priority of people who should
get this vaccine
are our frontline health care workers
and elderly americans those who
are over 65 years of age and who have
been proven throughout this entire
uh pandemic are many many times more
likely to die
if they get this virus than those who
are younger
and healthy unfortunately
the recommendations that are coming out
of the cdc do not reflect
what has been established by science and
this is the warning that that i'm
calling out
right so what is that what their work
essentially is
they they have um
they're making politically driven
decisions that are essentially putting
the lives of elderly american seniors
at risk where they're saying okay well
yes frontline healthcare workers are
getting it first as they should right
now
but those who are getting it next are
people who they deem as essential
workers which is about 87 million
americans and those who fall
under everything from uh people who are
working at the grocery store people who
are manning the
the cash register at a liquor store to
lawyers
to people working in the media to people
working in transportation construction
corrections there's
essentially a laundry list of people who
they have deemed as essential workers
of any age who who they're saying should
either get the vaccine before
our seniors or who our seniors need to
compete with
in order to get this vaccine and this is
what is
is uh it's it's just mind-boggling
because
this is coming from people who claim to
be medical experts uh
but they're not making their decisions
based on science they're instead
making politically motivated decisions
where do you fall
generally on lockdowns and the rest of
it i mean you know we're coming up
unbelievably on basically almost a year
i mean it's been about 10 months already
of sort of lockdowns masks the whole
thing we were told two weeks to flatten
the curve
and now we're being told oh maybe a
hundred day
federal mass mandate i'm in california
where
everything is locked down i mean the
main street i live off of
it looks like a ghost town i mean it
genuinely looks like a ghost town
do you believe this should have been
left to the states and are you kind of
shocked at how it's now 10 months later
and we kind of forget
where we started from um
i mean there's no question that this is
a this is a major public health
issue given not only how infectious this
virus is but also the recent mutation
that we've seen occur in in the uk and
other places and now i think colorado
has gotten the first view
of an even more infectious version of
kovid
so i think that they're you know the
baseline standard of public health
precautions do need to be taken
uh which you know it is it's it's you
know wear masks protect yourself protect
others and wash your hands and socially
distance
um the the lack of a national strategy
with regards to
testing has worsened the situation where
still as we sit here today it is
incredibly difficult
to get a test if you test
more frequently and more people then you
have the ability for people to act on
that information and take precautions
themselves there's no reason why we
shouldn't have these capabilities
deployed
all across the country there's no reason
why we shouldn't have medical grade
masks available to every
american which are actually most
effective versus the cloth masks that
that so many people are forced to use
because they can't get medical masks
and then um you know the issue with
the nonsensical decisions that a lot of
state and local leaders are making for
example in california i saw
i think it's a viral video at this point
where this guy is out paddle boarding in
the water by himself
and was apprehended by police both in
the water and
on land how does that make any sense we
had here locally there was a decision
made for a while like no one's allowed
to go outdoors
no one is allowed to leave your home
unless for you know you're going to the
doctor you're going to the grocery store
but we know that people who are how's
the weather in hawaii again
usually pretty sunny pretty sunny
which we know is better for you know
increasing your immunity exercise is
good for you
uh they said okay well we'll let people
out but like uh
we'll open up the hikes again but you
can only go by yourself
you can't go with anybody like okay so i
can't go hiking with my husband
we live together um and how safe is it
for and one person to go out on a hike
in the mountains by them
but i mean it's just you can there's so
many different examples of of
really nonsensical decisions that again
have not been made based on
science and and how best to help protect
our communities and protect people's
health and well-being and the more
and then of course the last i'll mention
is how we are all told nationally
by these so-called medical experts that
uh
gathering in large groups of people
creates a great harm and a great risk
but all of a sudden if there's a a mass
gathering
for a political purpose that these
experts agree with then it's okay
and it's fine and and so there's no
surprise in my mind why so many people
are throwing like the bs flag on the
field
and saying you know i i don't trust you
guys i don't trust you guys how can we
trust what you are telling us
is true and that this will actually help
protect our neighbors and friends and
community
when there's there's no consistency and
these decisions are not being made
based on proven medical science what do
you think just sort of philosophically
about
lockdowns in general i mean they haven't
been proven to work
california is clearly an example of that
i spent last week in florida where
everything was open and the numbers are
are actually less and people are out
there and they're living their lives
but philosophically just sort of the
amount of people that we've just put out
of work and we know depression is up and
alcoholism is up and drug use is up and
and all of this stuff um
it's almost like people are just kind of
forgetting what freedom is like you
really within 10 months you can
completely forget it yeah i think that
there's
i don't think that one can say yes
lockdowns or no lockdowns as a broad
statement
i think that there are certain things
that that
could and should be done in a public
health crisis like the one that we are
seeing to try to contain a virus
like this but again those decisions
should be made based on
uh the science and what we know will be
most effective i think one of the
ineffective things that we've seen occur
is how big box retailers
for example have been allowed to remain
completely open and conducting their
business as per usual with large numbers
of people going in and out every single
day
and yet you know the small mom and pop
shop on the on the corner
has been forced to shut down because
they are they are not essential
this this how are you choosing who is
essential and non-essential who gets to
stay open and who gets to close
and frankly it's been the biggest
corporations
who have benefited the most who've been
allowed to stay open
throughout this pandemic whereas the the
small businesses the restaurants and and
small shops in our communities
have not been allowed to open
their doors again points to
politically motivated decisions rather
than decisions made in the best
interests of the people
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell